[Musique]
enfin
du pacifique à l'océan indien les
poissons à mâchoires dominent les mères
[Musique]
équipées d'une mâchoire de nageoires et
une colonne vertébrale flexible ces
poissons peuvent bouger vite et devenir
des prédateurs c'est grâce à ces traits
qui aurait supplanté leurs ancêtres les
poissons sans mâchoires des poissons
presque tous disparu aujourd'hui
mais une nouvelle découverte publiée
récemment dans la revue alien 3 jean
vient nuancer cette hypothèse est
certain d'être est associé aux poissons
avec mâchoire serait apparu plutôt prévu
dans l'évolution
[Musique]
on vient de les découvrir sur un fossile
de poisson primitifs sans mâchoires
vieux de 380 millions d'années trouvé il
ya plus d'un siècle dans le pacte ni aux
achats en gaspésie on l'a sorti des
tiroirs pour le soumettre à de nouvelles
analyses
c'est le fan et rops difficile de
comprendre les parties fines de ce
squelette imprimée dans la pierre
marion chevry n'est paléontologue à
l'université du québec à rimouski a
réussi à déchiffrer ce casse tête
pour identifier les parties du corps de
l'ancien poisson la paléontologue fait
des dessins de précisions elle place le
fossile sous une loupe binoculaire un
système de miroir permet de faire des
calculs du fossile sur du papier
[Musique]
ses dessins sont alors numérisés sur
ordinateur ou l'anatomie du fossile est
décrite en détail
elle découvre que le fan et raps à une
proto colonne vertébrale qui commence à
se différencier selon la portion du
corps de l'animal
certaines vertèbres sont ainsi plus
grosse que d'autres cela permet de
supporter de nouvelles structures comme
ce proto bassin
grâce à ces évolutions du squelette les
prochaines générations développeront des
pères de nageoires qui leur permettront
de se déplacer plus efficacement ses
nageoires deviendront plus tard des
pâtes des vertébrés terrestres
[Musique]
accolé au proto bassin de 9 en europe
ceux des organes non encore répertoriées
chez cette espèce pique la curiosité de
la chercheuse
la forme la position
ça ressemble des organes d'être mission
l'équivalent du phallus chez les
poissons se pourrait-il que des organes
aussi évoluer soit apparue chez un
poisson aussi primitif
en plaçant le fossile sous rayons x dans
un microscope électronique on obtient
des signatures chimiques du spécimen ce
qui permet de distinguer l'os du
cartilage et de la roche
le résultat est clair il s'agit de
cartilage le fan et rops possèderait
donc des organes d'être mission
ces tubes de cartilage permettait aux
mâles de déposer leurs semences au sein
de la femelle évitant ainsi leur
dispersion par les courants marins
une façon d'assurer le succès de la
reproduction
[Musique]
avec ses découvertes l'histoire de
l'évolution du poisson doit être révisée
des poissons sans mâchoires ne sont
finalement pas si primitive que cela